I hope you made some good progress on both of these tasks.
Ask us questions on the discussion forum, if you are stuck some place.
In this and the next video, I will highlight some common constraints related
issues that students in this class have been having.
So I changed the image for this button and it now looks like a rabbit.
I also want to make sure that it lines up well with the other button, so
I will move it around and use these blue dotted lines as my guide.
There.
Now, to add constraints to this button, I can hold down the Ctrl key on
my keyboard, and add a constraint to the top space.
After that, I can add a constraint to the trailing space also.
Now, I want to make sure that the leading space here,
is equal to the trailing space here.
To do that, what I can do, is select this constraint and
drag out the utility area, and under size inspector,
I can see that the value of this constraint is a constant 30 points.
So I can now select the other constraint, the trailing space constraint, and
change its value to 30 also.
Finally for the star button, let me scroll down a bit so we can see it properly,
I can add a constraint so that we center it horizontally.
And I can also make sure that it is pinned at a constant distance away from
the bottom of the phone.
Okay, let me run this project and see how it looks.
I'm going to go to the second screen, and there it is.
All three buttons are showing up in the correct location, although,
it seems these two buttons are way too close to each other.
I will let you play around with the leading constraint here and the trailing
constraint here, so that these two buttons look evenly spaced on the screen.